bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 le politique spéciale municipal 2020
sur tv 78 je reçois aujourd'hui
catherine perrotin raufast bonjour
bonjour du sur ce plateau vous êtes tête
de liste réinventons elancourt liste
soutenue par le parti socialiste le
parti communiste europe ecologie les
verts nouvelle donne mais aussi
génération le mouvement de benoît hamon
dont vous êtes adhérentes
c'est bien ça exactement alors c'est un
soutien au niveau local c'est à dire que
sur votre liste on retrouve toutes ces
différentes tendances
c'est ma police on retrouve des gens qui
sont effectivement adhérent au parti que
vous avez cités mais il ya également
beaucoup de gens qui ne sont adhérents à
aucun parti
il y à des citoyens qui sont engagés
depuis très longtemps dans les
associations de la ville des gens qui
sont pour lesquels c'est leur premier
engagement dans une liste municipale
vous ne revendiquez pas une étiquette
plus qu'une autre
c'est une mise de son site une liste de
sensibilité de gauche
vous étiez candidates sont néanmoins en
2014 déjà sur la liste menée par michel
b socialiste pourquoi pourquoi repartir
au combat cette fois ci encore et cette
fois ci en tant que tête de liste
alors écoutez j'ai j'ai été choisi pour
mener la liste
réinventons elancourt j'ai été choisi
parce que je suis une habitante d'el en
cours depuis 33 ans
je suis médecin de famille ce qui
suppose des qualités d'empathie d'
écoute des capacités à prendre des
décisions parfois difficiles le sens des
responsabilités et le sens du travail en
équipe vous vous dites avoir été choisi
parce qu'il ya une démarche particulière
différente qu'on retrouve beaucoup cette
année sur ce scrutin des élections
municipales plus participative plus
citoyenne les premières réunions ont eu
lieu sont sans tête de liste et
d'ailleurs c'est un binôme qui a été
aussi désigné et vous recevront ce soir
mais il ya également jean claude potier
qui est avec vous au sein de celui non
donc la démarche a été très différente
et s'est construite sur plusieurs mois
plusieurs années sur plusieurs années
environ deux ans et demi et
effectivement le but premier n'était pas
que quelqu'un se déclare comme candidat
mais notre but premier c'est de
construire un projet pour ils encourent
et donc nous avons trois axes principaux
de projets le premier axe c'est celui
effectivement de la démocratie
participative et la façon dont notre
équipe mène cette campagne préfigure la
façon dont nous travaillerons au conseil
municipal quand nous serons élus par
exemple comme vous le dites j'ai été
choisi comme tête de liste avec comme
binôme jean claude potier jantes le
petit et lui est ingénieur
il était jusqu'à très récemment
présidents des trois à la plus grosse
association élan courtoise et nous
voulons participer à cette eau proposer
des conseils municipaux qui
fonctionneront en binôme parce que nous
pensons que les décisions collectives
sont plus structuré plus réfléchi mais
néanmoins alors on va revenir sur les
différents axes de programme au cours de
cet entretien mais lorsque vous dites
mettre plus de participation si j'ai
bien compris au sein du conseil
municipal au sein des décisions qui sont
prises pour la commune au final ça
revient à faire des mini référendum des
mini concertation sur chacun des sujets
est-ce que ça risque pas aussi de
ralentir le processus est ce que c'est
pas un peu compliqué de gouverner de
cette façon une fois qu'on est élu on a
un programme et il faut aussi mettre en
oeuvre alors pour nous la démocratie ce
n'est pas seulement donner sa voix
tous les six ans à un homme ou à une
femme c'est la vraie démocratie
municipale c'est écouter les habitants
construire avec le projet et rendre
compte des actions municipales
donc effectivement cela peut prendre du
temps mais nous pensons que c'est
meilleur pour la ville il ya plusieurs
réunions qui sont prévues au cours du
mois de janvier justement pour
construire ce programme qui est encore
forcément en cours de construction comme
pour toutes les listes et dans toutes
les communes
je peux citer le jeudi 7 janvier
notamment ce sera la salle willy brandt
à la clé de saint pierre ou encore le 23
janvier ce sera
plus anglais sur l'écologie elle ce sera
la maison de quartier de lavilledieu
l'écologie aussi points importants de
votre programme
l'écologie est un axe majeur de notre
programme on peut dire que c'est le
drame actuel
les jeunes sont dans la rue les jeunes
nous bouscule à ce sujet et ils ont
raison
toute décision prise dans une
municipalité doit être prise en fonction
de cette urgence écologique et nous
souhaitons que et l'encours soit une
ville pionnière dans ce domaine alors
l'écologie dont on peut d'ailleurs dire
qu'elle est créatrice d'emplois
ça suppose beaucoup de domaines ça va
des déplacements dans la ville de
l'alimentation dans les cantines hallal
à la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments municipaux comme privés on aa
et long cours une chance formidable
c'est d'avoir des espaces naturels en
coeur de ville
ces espaces naturels nous voulons les
préserver les conserver et les enrichir
par exemple les jardins familiaux nous
voulons les valoriser la colline de la
revanche nous voulons l'aménager en
espace nature et loisirs au bénéfice des
familles et des sportifs vous parlez de
cette colline la revanche aujourd'hui
appeler aux collines d'elancourt un
d'ailleurs cette colline d'elancourt sur
lequel il est prévu et c'est dans le
cadre du dossier paris 2024 d'accueillir
des épreuves aussi un cycliste vous êtes
opposés à ce projet vous préfériez
préféreriez voir la chamonix qui s'est
manifestée récemment récupéré ces
épreuves en tout cas à ma connaissance
il n'est pas du tout acquis que les
épreuves de vtt se passe sur la colline
des langues aujourd'hui dans le dossier
c'était la ville d'elancourt c'est la
ville et long cours qui a été qu'ils
avaient candidaté qui a été retenue dans
le projet si chamonix de l'obtenir se
serait enlevé à elancourt mais à
l'origine c'était très bon court donc
votre point de vue nous ce que nous
voulons c'est aménager deux femmes
manière durable et écologique la colline
d'elancourt pour les familles et les
sportifs dans une perspective vraiment
municipal parle peut-être aussi un peu
des difficultés rencontrées par les
différentes communes des difficultés
financières notamment dotations de
l'état qui sont en baisse il faut faire
des économies un petit peu partout à
chaque fois sur le plan des finances
quelles seraient vos goûts vos
propositions est ce que ça fait partie
de vos thèmes de campagne aussi un
budget ça se construit selon des choix
voilà donc nous nous choisirons non pas
en fonction du coût mais en fonction des
propositions que nous ferons sur les
différents enjeux sur le mandat qui va
débuter à partir de 2020 et il y à vous
l'avez on en a parlé rapidement ces jeux
olympiques il y a aussi les transports
il ya aussi un centre aquatique qui va
voir le jour bientôt prochainement sur
sur la commune de maurepas qui sera en
lien avec l encours c'est un projet que
vous approuvez nounou squido différents
tracts je vous ai plutôt lui vous étiez
critique sur ce projet mais il est
attendu par la population
c'est vrai que la population attend une
piscine depuis des années nous nous
étions plus favorable à rénover
l'ancienne piscine plutôt qu'à la
détruire et nous sommes favorables à la
construction d'une piscine dans laquelle
on peut nager un espace aqualudique qui
va te coûter très cher à la commune et
dont nous n'avons pas vraiment les
contrats définitifs
nous n'avons pas connaissance nous
paraît être un engagement périlleux on
aura l'occasion d'y revenir bien
évidemment sur ces différents dossiers
puisque le temps passe et les candidats
viendront échanger au cours d'un débat
vous le savez et puis nous aurons
l'occasion de vous redonner les
différentes dates sur notre antenne tout
même une question si on regarde les
résultats jusqu'à présent sur la commune
d'elancourt 2014
la gauche totalisent un peu moins de 24%
en 2008 c'était un peu moins de 35%
comment vous pensez endiguer cette
érosion le maire sortant qui a confirmé
sa nouvelle candidature pour un nouveau
mandat a quasiment été élu à chaque fois
au premier tour comment
vous pensez l'emporter cette fois ci
qu'est ce qui fera la différence nous
notre projet donc comme je vous le
disais il porte sur les trois axes
majeurs que sont l'urgence écologique la
démocratie participative est une ville
une ville pour tous les âges
une ville plus sociale plus solidaire
parce que ce que nous constatons
actuellement c'est qu'il encoure est un
peu à l'arrêt elle manque de créativité
elle manque d'imagination elle manque
d'événements fédérateurs qui crée des
liens
les jeunes sont actuellement abandonnée
par la municipalité et c'est pour nous
une priorité que de changer cela nous
voulons modifier le quotient familial
pour qu'il soit plus juste pour les
familles
nous voulons créer recréer du lien dans
dés lors de temps ou de lieu de
rencontre voilà pour nous ils en vendent
et les projets nous nous voulons créer
des projets intergénérationnels proche
des habitants ou par les innovations la
ville d'elancourt était aussi connu pour
ses projets autour du numérique à
l'école par exemple vous parlez
d'animation la commanderie d'elancourt
multiplient des animations aussi sous
l'égide de la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ça ne suffit pas lors de nos rencontres
nous constatons que les jeunes sont au
pied des immeubles
ils s'ennuient ils n'ont aucun lieu
d'accueil
aucun lieu pour se retrouver donc non ça
ne suffit pas merci d'être venus et
catherine perron tinrent face aux est
candidate donc sur cette ville
d'elancourt ans et à nous y reviendrons
sur ce scrutin au cours des prochaines
semaines
dépôt des listes officielles le 27
février et puis vous le savez le 15 mars
ce sera le premier tour merci encore à
vous nous poursuivons cette édition du 7
8 politique
direction magny les hameaux où la
campagne débute tout juste de liste
pourrait se présenter face au maire
sortant bertrand ou lyon l'une menée par
lionel lindemann conseiller municipal
d'opposition baptisé manie citoyens elle
annonce vouloir à désenclaver la commune
crée un marché notamment à l'autre liste
serait celle de dominique grattepain
elle est en cours de constitution
l'homme a déjà été conseiller municipal
de la majorité à 2,95 à 2001 sous le
mandat de jacques l'eau lloze quant au
maire divers gauche bertrand guillon il
n'a pas encore annoncé officiellement sa
candidature mais il mène des ateliers
citoyens afin de préparer son programme
plusieurs dates sont annoncées en
janvier à retrouver sur le site internet
de sa campagne ensemble pour manille
point fr à guyancourt la campagne est un
peu plus lent c'est déjà avec cinq
listes présentées grégory pape vient de
dévoiler les premiers points de son
programme et les premiers noms des
personnes qui vont l'accompagner
reportage michael ennemis dans une
réunion publique pour présenter son
équipe
grégory pape de la liste nouvel élan à
guyancourt soutenu par lrm investi la
ville à jean monnet ce mercredi 8
janvier au programme échanges et prise
de parole au total une vingtaine de
colistiers s'est présenté hradiste
années diverses hétérogènes le nist avec
des personnes qui sont neuf en politique
toutefois nous avons des personnes qui
sont déjà expérimentés qui sont déjà au
sein du conseil municipal ou qui l'ont
été pour nous accompagner
mais nous souhaitons une liste avec de
l'énergie sur cette liste on retrouve
notamment jean-luc ev cyr l'ancien
président de la faculté versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de 2012 à 2016
ou encore jean-luc arias conseiller
municipal dans la ville lui ne sera pas
sur la liste mais affiche son soutien
robert cadalbert président socialiste de
saint quentin en yvelines de 1998 à 2000
14 étaient présents dans la salle
grégory pape est tout à fait dans cette
logique dans ces jeux et profonde de
faire en sorte qu'il faut être ouvert et
ouvert sur les projets
c'est pas pour ça que
si on travaille les gens de gauche et de
droite on s'assoit sur ses principes
mais ce qui est le plus important c'est
la dynamique sur les projets sur le
l'ensemble du territoire
la prochaine réunion publique de grégory
pape sont organisées fin février dans la
ville aux élections municipales il sera
opposé à rodolphe baril de la liste
ensemble agissons pour but en cours
olivier paréja deux décident ensemble
pour guyancourt au maire sortant
françois morton et ahmed ben bella à des
qte de l'union des démocrates musulmans
français
côté agenda à présent nicolas il
présentera son programme le 25 janvier
aux clayes-sous-bois l'actuel élus
d'opposition qui fédère la gauche dans
ce scrutin attendra les électeurs à
l'école henri proulx nicolas dainville à
la verrière lui adressera ses voeux à la
population lui aussi actuels élus
d'opposition il organisera cette
cérémonie le 16 janvier au scarabée et
puis patrick jane eyre candidats à
plaisir tiendra une réunion publique le
6 février
ancien élu de la majorité il défie cette
fois ci la maire sortante joséphine
coleman ce berger rendez vous mardi
prochain pour un nouveau 7,8 politiques
spéciales municipal 18h45 où chaque jour
dans le code dans le journal au
quotidien donc 18 heures très belle
soirée
[Musique]